there's a racial Justice Advocate who
has gone viral thanks to our friend over
there at Libs of Tik Tok she's gone
viral for explaining to her audience why
showing up on time is white supremacy as
a racial Justice Advocate I'm often
invited to give talks or to do workshops
where I talk to white people about race
a big part of my practice is to offer
real life stories examples that type of
thing that help white people to be able
to identify white supremacy in everyday
life my husband's family is white and I
often use a cultural difference between
my family and his family as a way to
help white people see their whiteness
there's one example that I use that
always gets a ton of push back my
husband and I were late to our first
Thanksgiving with his family I say late
because it started at 12:00 we got there
at 12:10 but whenever we got there at
1210 everybody was already sat down and
eating I didn't know that I Ed this
illustration to point out that different
cultures have different understandings
of time lateness and what it means to be
polite without fail a white person will
push back and say that lateness is
impolite I always use this as a
teachable moment I usually ask a series
of pointed questions that challenge
their assumptions sometimes it takes a
lot of work but by the end they're able
to identify how white cultural dominance
Works in this one small area of Life
which opens the door for them to start
peeling the
onion okay we've all seen this video a
million times not this exact video but
versions of this video with versions of
this woman so what's it
about why why are people being so mean
to the white people why is so now you're
saying that just show up on time is
white supremacy why why is this woman
doing this you know why this woman's
doing
this because her white audience wants
her to that's
why really we cannot blame the black
people even the BLM activists for this
they are giving their audience what they
want who is This Woman's audience This
Woman's audience is liberal white people
her job is to go to Liberal white people
and make them feel guilty and then they
pay her money for that it's it's like a
a dominatrix who has a bunch of weirdo
clients who want her to beat beat them
up or so whip them with chains or
something that's what this is and she
gives the audience what they want the
customer is always right this woman
obviously doesn't hate white people
because This Woman's husband is white or
at the very least the H the woman's
husband was adopted by a white family
right she says my husband's family is
white which means either he's white or
he's adopted and he's and he's
culturally white either way though she's
got a lot of familiarity with with white
culture and white people and she
involves herself in them she's probably
spends most of her time with white
people because the people she works with
are white and the people that she has
her romantic life with are broadly white
so it's not that she hates that she
she's maow moou the flat catchers
because they're asking her to that's
what this is really
about th this is about a masochistic
perversion and you know we talk a a lot
about perversions in our culture because
we live in a very perverted and decadent
time but this is just another example of
it this is just another example of
people Desiring something that is
harmful to them ultimately bad for them
but they want it anyway just like
someone who's a bit fat wants more candy
bars than than he ought to have just
like uh someone who is sexually decadent
wants all sorts of sterile and
hedonistic sexual
activities uh so too with the racial
grievance this this is entirely about
masochistic white if the white people
stopped being masochistic if the white
liberals stopped feeling guilty for the
color of their skin this whole industry
would disappear overnight all of the BLM
stuff all the Georgia it would disappear
overnight but it's still here because
the audience wants it right now go to
policy genius.com no one likes to talk
about life insurance but it is incred
inly important and you need to include
it in your financial planning this year
start shopping now with policy genius
policy genius is where you go to get
life insurance period find the right
policy to protect your family today give
yourself the peace of mind that comes
with knowing that if something were to
happen to you your family can cover all
their expenses while getting back on
their feet it is the responsible thing
to do you have an obligation to do it
and it will help you sleep easier at
night policy genius's technology makes
it incredibly easy to compare life
insurance quotes from America's Top
insurers in just a few clicks you
already have a life insurance policy
through work that might not offer enough
protection for your family's needs it
may not follow you if you leave your job
you need a backup plan with policy
genius you can find life insurance
policies that start at just 292 bucks
per year for $1 million of coverage some
options offer same day approval and
avoid unnecessary medical exams policy
genius has licensed agents who can help
you find the best fit for your needs
when they make it this easy there is no
excuse not to do it policy genius works
for you not the insurance companies they
don't have any incentive to recommend
one insurer over the other so you can
trust they are giving you the absolute
best guidance save time and money give
your family a financial safety net
policy genius right now policygenius.com
or click the link in the description to
get your free life insurance quotes and
see how much you could save
policygenius.com
a lot of people are scratching their
heads over a trump truth social post
that came out yesterday and it was a it
was a picture half the screen is Elvis
Presley and half the screen is Donald
Trump and uh tweet it says
uh lots of people have said that I look
a lot like Elvis for so many years many
people have been saying that what do you
think people are scratching what what is
he even talking about this
is beyond policy this is my favorite
part part of Trump's political style
because this kind of a
post is funny it's weird and it's
totally
disarming the the libs have to respond
to it it drives them crazy and they have
to call them an idiot and they have to
call him distracted but the thing that
the libs are most upset about when it
comes to these sorts of posts and Trump
makes them all the time is that it it
makes it much harder for them to portray
Trump as
Hitler this Le
this this kind of
bizarre little show it makes it very
hard Hitler doesn't make a post like
that Hitler never does the picture where
it's half Hitler half Elvis or half I
don't know I don't know who the singer
would be in those days half
um actually I actually don't know who
would be The Mills Brothers or something
probably not uh that doesn't happen
right Trump has this bit of levity and
it this is something that a lot of the
critics that Trump has driven mad don't
really understand is that they see Trump
as being this totally narcissistic
self-serious guy he's not self-serious
at all and even below that level of
bragado doio you know he puts his name
in Gold letters on buildings and he
talks about how Grady is below that
Trump seems to me to demonstrate more
humility than most politicians I was
reminded of this when the Brett
Kavanaugh hearing was going on and
remember ju Justice Kavanaugh he was
asked about a party he went to in high
school when he was 16 or something they
said did you drink beer in high school
Justice Kavanaugh and he said I like
beer yeah I drink beer and they asked
president Trump about this and he gave
what I felt was the perfect answer I can
honestly say I never had a beer in my
life okay right it's one of my only good
traits I don't drink whenever they're
looking for something good I say I never
had a glass of alcohol I've never had
alcohol I've just you know for whatever
reason
can you imagine if I had what a mess I'd
be would I be the I'd be the world's
worst it's a great line and you hear a
lot of those kind of lines from Trump
right which I'm the greatest I'm the
smartest only I can save the country but
then you get this spit he goes look I
can say I'm probably the only person you
can say I've never had beer in my life
it's the only good thing you can say
about me is my only good trait could you
imagine if I had be I'd be the worst I'd
be could you imagine right that's
an example of humility it's self
effacing a lot of the bragado doio it's
just the New
Yorkers are are better able to spot this
kind of thing from Trump I remember in
2016 when Trump came onto the scene
really as a prominent candidate and
everyone in the conservative movement
hated him Drew claven and I were two of
the only people who said I don't know
he's kind of kind he's kind of funny I
kind of like him no coincidence I think
that Drew and I both grew up in New York
and this is how New Yorkers
talk and it's it's just it's fun I like
it it the weird Elvis post it reveals
the man to be human that that post was
not written by political Consultants
okay he was probably just batting it
around one day even even if it were
written by political Consultants it it's
it's funny it's weird it's it's just
it's not the kind of thing that any
other politician posts it makes you
think this guy's human we know he writes
his own tweets back when he was on
Twitter we know he writes a lot of this
caps the misspellings talking about mik
pinsky's face and you you might say well
that's not disciplined it's not focused
on the message yeah whatever at least I
know I'm talking to a human being and
that goes a long way in politics and
whether you love the guy or whether you
hate the guy a lot of career politicians
have tried to ape that style in recent
years
unsuccessfully that is a that is a kind
of political talent that you pretty much
cannot learn man what a great clip that
was now hold up hey wait stop stop ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nolles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time